hey I'm Jenn Harris senior food writer
at the Los Angeles Times I'm also
obsessed with fried chicken and I call
myself the unofficial fried chicken
queen of Los Angeles
today we're in downtown LA at Grand
Central Market to check out lucky bird
he's one of the best new fried chicken
spots in the city will be meeting with
Chef Chris Dane who's gonna tell us
exactly why the chicken here is so
crispy and delicious
bonus points he's going to be sharing
three recipes with us let's do this I'm
Christine chef/owner of lucky bird Grand
Central Market we wanted to kind of
showcase a Los Angeles type fried
chicken today we're gonna show you three
of our most popular dishes here so first
up we have the chicken sandwich so we
get a boneless skin-on chicken thigh we
put it in a chicken Brian it's got lemon
juice salt sugar it's got water
aromatics like garlic and thyme and bay
leaf and some lemon peels and we
submerge our chicken in it for up to
eight hours pull it out let the chicken
dry overnight
what's chickens been dried we bring it
into a dredge of AP flour paprika salt
and garlic powder
we use a flower called Wondra flour and
it does not absorb grease like a normal
AP flour will so it'll keep your chicken
a little bit lighter and a little bit
crispier and it won't have that kind of
heavy feeling and way down feeling when
you're eating it into buttermilk after
that with our homemade hot sauce and
then into our Wondra flour which is the
instant flour and then we'll drop it
into our pressure fryers and that helps
retain a lot of moisture it helps cook
our chicken to the appropriate levels as
we need it they fry for about eight
minutes and with resting they're
completely cooked all the way through
we'll take our buns that we get from a
local bakery and we'll slather them with
some chicken fat or some schmaltz and
toast them on the griddle once they're
toasted we'll schmear some paprika aioli
on them and we have house-made pickles
and some lettuce that we put on there as
well
and that's how you make our chicken
sandwich so excited eat this fried
chicken right now I have to do anything
all day this is our fried chicken
sandwich
enjoy
right away look at this big monster a
nice squishy bun this is dark meat dark
meat is key to a good juicy chicken
sandwich it's fried amazingly you see
how the skin and the breading are not
separated from the chicken this coating
is so crisp it basically shatters
there's a wholly-owned here is nuts
lots of nice acid for the pickles to
kill our sandwich so next up we're doing
our chicken and waffles we went on the
more savory route when it comes to the
waffles we'll get our AP flour we'll get
our hot sauce powder yeast baking soda
we'll get our salt and then we'll get
our wet ingredients which are eggs
buttermilk a little bit of water a
little bit of chicken fat and some
butter and we'll mix everything together
and it's important to let this batter
rise we'll add it to our waffle maker
about 3 and 1/2 minute cook time so
every chicken waffle comes with a
chicken breast and then one dark piece
either leg or thigh
and it's served with a habanero honey
and that's our chicken and waffle recipe
look at the crunch on this
and I love that he added to it with that
little bit of lemon zest and rolled in
sea salt on top girls get into his
waffles
because he uses they used to do-- such a
savoury super fluffy waffles seems like
a doughnut waffle this is the perfect
bite every time
and finally our buffalo bird this is our
version of a spicy chicken sandwich we
make our own hot sauce here with Fresno
chilies habaneros garlic salt and
vinegar we let that ferment for about a
week then we'll blend that up and once
the hot sauce is made we're able to turn
that into a buffalo sauce so I'll fry
our boneless skin-on thigh pieces and
once it comes out of the fryer we'll dip
it directly into this buffalo sauce and
completely coat the entire thing with
this nice saucy spicy and caution that
we made we slather a little bit of
buttermilk dressing on there some
pickled jalapenos and our homemade
coleslaw goes on top just kind of cool
you off just a little bit and that's the
Buffalo bird toaster sandwiches here
whoa heat level is good everyone is into
hot chicken right now I'm an OG buffalo
fan ever since I discovered Frank's
redhot this is like the best buffalo
chicken wing you've ever had smashed
into a fantastic sandwich and then he
has this fantastic slaw on here so farm
up ranch dressing it's like you're
dipping her wings and eating them Christ
thank you so much for showing us how to
make those incredible recipes the
chicken was so so good thank you so much
and you're welcome back any time if you
guys want to try Chris's fried chicken
sandwich and more fried chicken be sure
to head to our fried chicken party it's
happening as part of the Los Angeles
Times football in LA on May 10th and if
you want more information you can check
out the link in description I'll see you
guys there
[Music]